[Music]
welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you so much mitzi uh it's such a
pleasure to be here
if you guys don't know me i'm chanel ali
you might recognize me from mtv's girl
code i was in the last season of that
show which was also
the last season of that show so you're
welcome the pleasure is all mine
i feel comfortable with you guys i want
to just be honest and let you know that
i'm a biracial person i'm biracial which
is funny to me
every time i say it because i feel
pretty black
i feel very black every day when i wake
up
and go outside but growing up i didn't
know i was biracial
had no idea i was biracial tubs in
junior high a girl ran up to me at
school very out of breath like chanel
i saw you last night at target with this
old white lady
and she was buying you a bra what is
going
on and i was like whoa chelsea
that don't even sound like me you know i
was worried about my reputation then i
thought about it
and i was like i was at target last
night but i was there
with my grandmother and she is not oh
so then i went home and i walked up to
my grandmother that day
bold as brass i pointed in her face and
i said hey
are you white and she said
yes what did you think i was and i said
i never thought about it before
i knew that i was black because of b-e-t
so i just assumed by association my
grandmother was probably black too like
i know she wasn't very dark-skinned and
she didn't really
handle beach days as well as others but
we all got our stuff
who was i to judge she said no i'm 100
italian which means you are part of town
she told me that her parents
moved to this country from italy she
pulled out a picture frame
showed me two very nice looking white
people i said oh my gosh my whole life
i thought that was a brand new frame
and you just been waiting to feel it
everything is alive
like yeah i thought my grandmother was
lazy i didn't know she was white
now i'm 32 i'm 32 i know my ethnicity
but i'm still learning a lot about
myself it wasn't until this year that i
was able to admit that i'm the jealous
type
i'm one of those women but not in the
traditional sense more so in the sense
where i don't like it when my friends
tell me about their
other funny friends
i do not want to hear about that it
could be something small said to the
side like yeah i was at work the other
day
talking to jenny you know chanel she's
so funny you would love her i'm like
whoa whoa
whoa whoa what do you mean by that
what are you trying to say you you like
jenny's jokes
does jenny make you laugh
it's cool it's cool i just you know i
remember a time when
i could make your life just fine i
remember one time i made you laugh so
hard
you cried a little and then you peed a
little
i didn't tell nobody i'm a good friend
does uh jenny make you pee
[Music]
no i don't think she does no no no if
jenny's so
funny just tell me where
jenny lives
let's go to her house right now see if
she makes me laugh why do you keep
trying to leave i already locked the
door come sit down
and tell me about your funny friend
you know what's that but that's the most
honest joke
you guys have been kind i am chanel ali
thank you so much please keep it going
for mitzi
that was bananas i want more thanks for
coming to bananas
more i'm so excited to watch this next
performer light up
the banana more stage get ready for
comedy greatness
wow mitzi bananamore oh oh no i just had
a flashback to banana flavored fruit
wines
but anyway mitzi hello you
thank you for inviting me to join your
virtual coalition of comedy makers
now as you know i am no comedian or
grand farcier i'm but a humble thespian
but i never turned down an opportunity
to entertain
so in lieu of serenading you with
witticisms i thought i would just tell
her
well a brief story now many of you at
home may not know this but mitzi and i
we go way back yes back when dinosaurs
used to roam the earth
eons ago when we were but we bear by
performers
yes wide-eyed with grand aspirations of
ticking on the beg upper
and during those days we supported
ourselves as bar maidens in a
well a rather seedy drinking den called
the mug smuggler
it was an unnecessarily sticky and dark
establishment
with a proprietor who was a proper
snolly guster
yes he was a hairy hum gruffin who was
simply halitosis personified
and the frequenters were not much more
decorous than him i must say
i wouldn't have lasted six minutes in
that place if it wasn't for my
dear burn buddy extraordinaire mitzi who
attended that bar with the grit
and determination of a civil war field
nurse
now she was never one to suffer an
income poop and
well she became a mentor of sorts to me
and not just that she showed me how to
make a mai tai without bruising the ram
or how to handle a particularly
difficult
pattern shall we say no she taught me
how to stand just a bit taller
and to will never apologize for being
myself
and recently i've been thinking a lot
about that because during the most
trying of times you need those people in
your life
who bolster you and well they remind you
to breathe
right when it feels like life is going
to crackle your spirit
so thank you very much mitzi one never
forget
small acts of kindness nor did they
forget how odorifis that terrible bar
owner was
you'd think he had never heard of
antiperspirant
oh just the thought of him gives me the
golly wobbles
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has
kind of unfair give a little to the rest
of us
get your tissues ready because you're
going to be crying laughing at this next
comedian i will
personally be using a handkerchief
thanks mitzi it's so fantastic
to be here it's really fantastic to be
anywhere
i'm gonna give you a minute let you soak
it up you're checking out my haircut
you're looking at the necktie maybe it's
telling you something about me
maybe you're picking up the context
clues
if not i'll just tell you uh i swim in
the lady pond
i do my hunting in the lady forest
i'm gay sir you looked confused
i love when i tell audiences that i'm
gay because i can see all the women are
like
oh okay and the men are like hell yes
now it's a show
men love lesbians i i don't know why
even my dad when i told him he stood up
he said hey
she got that from me
which was a weird thing to say at church
but
he means well speaking of church we just
had a little easter happen
fantastic holiday easter is a fat kid's
favorite holiday
now a lot of people will try to tell you
that fat kids love halloween
no no we don't because on halloween
y'all make us walk around for that candy
and on easter that rabbit hippity hops
it to your door
clearly a superior candy infused
holiday what i did miss this year at
easter was visiting my nana
i love my nana y'all she is 88 years old
and one of the coolest women you will
ever meet in your life
and i love going over there y'all
because she's got a giant
tv she's got the biggest tv you've ever
i'm telling y'all they gave this woman
one
inch of tv for every year she's been
alive
and if she is awake the tv is on
and the show that she keeps it on is
family feud game show network all the
way
family feud we watch it morning noon and
night
and we one day we just we were up late
it was like 3 30
in the afternoon we couldn't take our
eyes off this particular
episode because the families were tied
the families are tied the point value is
tripled top three answers are on the
board
name something you put on a baked potato
my nana stands up and screams aluminum
foil
i mean she's not wrong but when the
number one answer was butter
she was mad when answers two and three
were sour cream and chives
she lost her mind y'all she stood up
i have been making baked potatoes since
1952.
okay i've made them without butter i've
made them without sour cream
i'm not entirely sure what the hell a
chive even is
but i have never in my life made a baked
potato without any damn aluminum foil
and then she just got up and went to bed
turned the tv off she was done with all
of us
she doesn't like it when i when i say
when i say hell
those are she doesn't like those words
she still calls people turkey
that's how she gets mad at him but she
says don't you ever worry talking like
that
i said listen here's the truth it
doesn't matter what i
say somebody could get offended i i
could
anything i could say anything in
somebody i could be telling a joke about
walmart and somebody would say
that's not funny my mama was killed by
fallen christ said
that's why that smiley face is wearing a
hard hat because of my mama
thanks so much y'all you've been
fantastic there's no
business like show business incredible